tél et puis on les disait lors le marché
du bio c'est un marché en pleine
expansion aujourd'hui de plus en plus de
français mangent bio et cela malgré un
prix plus élevé les grandes surfaces
s'intéressent à ce créneau qu'elles
savent pourtant limitée dans cinq ans il
estime que le bio ne représentera que 5%
du marché de la grande distribution mais
le respect de l'environnement fait
vendre les grandes surfaces l'ont bien
compris et cherche d'autres solutions
jean yves perrin jean francois monier
depuis deux ans le temple de
l'agriculture productiviste qu'est le
salon fait une petite place à la
chapelle du bio on y trouve plutôt des
grandes marques de distributeurs et
quelques coopératif se spécialiser mais
peu de petits producteurs vu le prix des
stands les accros du biou cost y faire
quelques emplettes et les producteurs
beaucoup de promo cardiologique s'il a
tenu un véritable engouement pour le bio
se boucher de limoges s'est converti il
ya deux ans résultat son chiffre
d'affaires explose allez on va dire
entre 40 et 50%
depuis deux ans depuis deux ans
notre éditeur ça nous met un peu dans
l'embarras parce que ça veut dire qu'on
a beaucoup de demandes et qu'on n'arrive
pas à la crise de la vache folle le
débat sur les organismes génétiquement
modifiés ont influencé une partie du
nouveau public du bio et le fait de
trouver ces produits en grandes surfaces
a contribué à la progression des ventes
elle devrait pourtant plafonné à 5% du
marché alors une marque d'hypermarchés
pourtant partenaire des agriculteurs
biologiques depuis deux ans lance
aujourd'hui à grand renfort de promotion
les produits issus de l'agriculture
raisonnée en jouant sur l'appétit du
public pour le respect de
l'environnement
la méthode emploi moins de pesticides
moins d'engrais chimiques moins
d'antibiotiques mais l on utilise quand
même cible de la marque 25% du marché du
frais dans cinq ans
nous a permis sans vie dable prise de
conscience de la part des consommateurs
et de la part de nous aussi distributeur
c'est vrai qu'il ouvre la voie à une
agriculture qui pour nous celle du
xxième siècle l'agriculture raisonnée il
ya notre optimisme naturel qui consiste
à dire plus tout le monde
un petit peu mieux et plus et mieux pour
tout le monde qu'on est favorable à ce
type de démarche par contre il faut pas
qu'il y ait confusion avec notre
pratique est beaucoup plus globale
les consommateurs seront utiles ou
voudront ils faire la différence alors
que les prix seront forcément
défavorable aux produits bio